مرحبًا ، أنا دكتور سانجاي جوبتا ، مضيف
بودكاست مطاردة الحياة في CNN ،
كم مرة تستيقظ
وتتذكر بالفعل الحلم الذي حلمت به وتتساءل عما إذا
كان له أي معنى أو غرض أو ما إذا
كان عشوائيًا بينما قد لا تكون كل
الأحلام شديدة أو  قوية أو حتى
لا تنسى الحقيقة هي أننا نحلم جميعًا بأن
تكون تجربة إنسانية عالمية
والأحلام هي أيضًا انعكاس جيد جدًا
لحياتنا اليقظة مخاوفنا
رغباتنا وتحدياتنا ،
لذلك لا شك أن الأحلام يمكن أن توفر
لنا رؤى جديدة
ويمكنك إنشاء أكثر ثراءً  عالم الأحلام من
خلال الانتباه إلى إجراءات وقت النوم
وأيضًا الاقتراب من الأحلام بقصد
إيقاف تشغيل تلك الشاشة ، حاول أن تجد بعض
الهدوء في وقت مبكر من الليل وعندما
تشعر بالنعاس تأكد
من أن تخبر نفسك أنك ستحلم
الليلة في الصباح  توقف مؤقتًا ، خذ بعض
الوقت للتفكير فيما تتذكره
وقم بتسجيل ومشاركة أحلامك مع العائلة
والأصدقاء ، إنها فرصة للإبطاء
والتعرف على شيء آخر نمتلكه
جميعًا  من الشائع
أننا نحلم
يمكنك سماع المزيد حول كيفية تحسين
صحتك ومطاردة الحياة أينما
حصلت على ملفاتك الصوتية